all right i have some
extraordinarily disturbing video to play
for you this is a new interview with
again i guess former trump fraud lawyer
sydney powell you might remember that
whether she was even trump's lawyer is
like a subject of debate she was having
meetings in the oval office which
certainly signals a connection to donald
trump at the same time the trump
campaign at one point put out a
statement when she went really bonkers
saying she's working on her own
we still don't really have answers to
that but she's delivered some very
strange interviews recently uh sydney
powell has now given an interview in
which she drags supreme court justice
samuel alito into the january sixth mess
the claim that she makes is that part of
the point of the january 6th riots
was
to delay things enough that samuel alito
would be able to intervene
and somehow give the election to trump i
mean you know how these things are it's
always like well exactly how it's not
clear
uh she gave an interview
on the stu peters show this is not a
program i'm familiar with but her claim
if she's right this is the most extreme
premeditated
uh criminality
including the highest levels of power
that maybe we've ever seen
if she's making it up she probably needs
a psych eval i mean i don't you know to
be totally honest i don't really know
which of the two it is uh but let's take
a look at this here is the interview uh
let's listen to sydney powell the audio
quality is terrible the video quality is
terrible but let's do our best to to try
to really understand what it is she's
claiming here heard untold election case
yes we were filing a 12th amendment
constitutional challenge to the process
that the congress was about to use under
the electoral act
provisions that simply don't jive with
the 12th amendment to the united states
constitution and justice alito was our
circuit justice for that louis gomer was
the plaintiff in our lawsuit and we were
suing the vice president to follow the
12th amendment as opposed to the
electoral
count act so our electoral college act
so that was the the main point and
nancy pelosi had finagled to file an
amicus brief in it there had been inside
goings-on in congress whereby i believe
it was steve scalise and mccarthy kept
her from being an actual party she
wanted to work her way into the case's
party but somehow politically that
didn't happen but so she got noticed
when we made her filing because she
wanted to file an omega spree for had
filed and to make us brief and um then
if you're confused you i mean the the
guy on the left looks as confused as as
you and i probably are
i'll try to explain what she's talking
about in a second although again if
these are just her delusions it really
there is no explanation
you know everything broke loose and she
had to really speed up
reconvening congress to get the vote
going before justice alito might have
issued an injunction to stop it all
which is what should have happened okay
so
the gist of what she seems to be saying
here
is that
the idea of the riot was to create a
delay
so that you could get a particular
amicus or as she says amicus brief
to the supreme court
with the idea that samuel alito again
i'm trying to interpret what a crazy
person saying but the idea is samuel
alito would be able to do something and
then
trump becomes president i guess or
something like that uh but they didn't
anticipate that nancy pelosi would so
quickly reconvene on january 6th late
really early january 7th it was kind of
the middle of the night you know
technically january 7th for much of it
and move forward and that that's what
interfered with this now
if this is true
and alito knew that this was the
expectation or you know partic said okay
it would be an incredible conspiracy
at the absolute highest level it would
have all been premeditated if powell is
to be believed um
samuel alito should be impeached okay
it also might just be completely made up
and i'm going to be very honest with you
it almost seems more likely to me i mean
sydney powell lies all the time
and she might be making all of this up
and that's its own problem and uh that
would be one possibility now the third
possibility is she believes this stuff
but it's not true like she's actually
delusional
and if that's the case you're really
talking psych evil i mean i'm gonna be
totally frank that that's what it is so
if what she says is true it would be
grounds for impeaching samuel alito
potentially
um if it's a lie then she's really a
crazy liar who's willing to just make up
anything
and if she believes it but it's
completely
imaginary
it's kind of a sad uh mental health sort
of uh situation
let's go to one more clip this is this
is funny because this is now the
interviewer
and i'm trying to figure out like what
is he
he's trying to explain what sydney
powell i guess said and it's like it's
even more confusing let's listen up the
coup why nancy pelosi had to hurry on
january 6th according to powell on the
very day of january 6 there was a one
last-ditch legal effort that might have
stopped the certification of disputed
electoral states by the congress a legal
challenge to the electoral count act a
130 year old law that governs the actual
electoral college process
now this law gives both the house and
senate explicit roles in evaluating
electoral slates
even though the 12th amendment to the
constitution only gives the house a role
in choosing the president okay so this
is a part of what they've been pushing
which is
we need to only the house should be
picking the president like the senate
shouldn't even have been involved
on january 6. this is another one of
these
it's sort of like
if i misspell my name i'm not taxable
like that was a whole movement at one
it's that type of movement and the stu
peters seems to be sort of sort of
explaining that
the senate as we know is only involved
in choosing a vice president right so
powell brought a lawsuit to overturn
that law but only filed at the afternoon
of january 6 while a bunch of people
were trampling would have been something
to think about sooner right through the
capital in what later would be referred
to as the great insurrection yeah now
that insurrection might have played to
her advantage by delaying the final
resolution of the election but then
nancy pelosi won upped her by
reconvening congress and finishing the
tally in the middle of the night
the next day supreme court justice alito
dismissed the case but according to
powell it might have been different if
that election wasn't already over
so i guess he's just explaining he he
if if i'm understanding him correctly my
understanding of what sydney powell is
claiming is accurate it doesn't make
what sydney powell is claiming any more
true so who knows what the truth is
maybe powell increasingly thinks she's
going down and she's seeing who can who
can i take down with me if i implicate a
lido maybe it helps me in some way the
bigger picture is the more we learn the
more premeditated this might have been
on january 6th allegedly involving more
and more parties whether any individual
claim is true honestly i don't know
because the people involved are so
dishonest rudy jenna ellis sidney powell
trump himself bannon
you know if these people had their way
the u.s would be a complete and total
theocracy and authoritarian christian
theocracy that's actually what we're
fighting against here
one of our sponsors is aura think about
all of your online accounts finances
your devices how are you protecting them
hacking
data breaches identity theft these are
bigger issues now than they've ever been
before
aura is a new type of security service
it protects your online data your
internet connection your devices with
one subscription you'll be alerted to
fraud and threats quickly like if your
online accounts or passwords were leaked
or if someone tried to open a bank
account in your name with an easy online
dashboard an alert sent straight to your
phone aura keeps you in control and
guides you through solving any issues
all plans come with a one million dollar
identity theft insurance to help recover
stolen funds so if you want to secure
your online presence from hackers and
scammers check out aura you'll get 40
off all plans when you go to aura.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video